ich habe ihnen heute mehr eine frage
mitgebracht sind politiker unsere diener
oder sind sie unsere genannten ich sage
der staat darf sich nicht anmaßen uns
erziehen zu wollen er muss sich selbst
wenn es zu unserem wohl ist er muss sich
so weit wie möglich aus unserem leben
heraushalten doch der trend geht
eindeutig in eine andere richtung das
erste freiheitlich demokratische land
wählen nun das rauchen verbieten
unser schrittweise das alter in dem es
erlaubt dass zigaretten zu kaufen soll
hört erhöht werden so dass jemand der
heute 14 jahre alt ist niemals in seinem
leben legal an zigaretten kommen kann
die begründung kommt eine in diesen
tagen seltsam bekannt vor es geht um die
entlastung des gesundheitssystems es
geht um die solidargemeinschaft
doch mit der gleichen logik könnte man
auch weißen zucker verbieten oder manche
sportarten oder auto fahren auch wenn
ich selbst das rauchen für eine plage
halte ich brauche selber und haben
schwierigkeiten von dieser sucht
loszukommen und wünsche mir eigentlich
dass ich nie damit in kontakt kommen
werden ich fürchte mich langsam oder
über griffigkeit des staates stück für
stück werden bewerbe gemacht und daran
gewöhnt dass der staat in unser leben
hinein forschen und das schlimmste ist
ich sehe gar keine gegenbewegung ich
sehe er dass die meisten bürger einen
strengen staat stichwort impfpflicht
geradezu herbeisehnen das macht mir
langsam sorge und ich bin gespannt wie
er dazu steht wäre mal interessant zu
wissen wie die neuseeländer damit
umgehen weil ich meine aber wir wissen
ja dass jedes verbot eigentlich
herausfordert dass das eine
gegenbewegung gibt und das ist die
illegalität gibt dh die werden anfangen
die fliegen dar australien um sich
zigaretten zu holen oder es gibt einen
riesigen schwarzmarkt so was ja immer ja
drogen ganze drogenkriminalität gibt es
seit abschaffung der drogen das heißt
das ist das womit die leben müssen dann
auf der anderen seite muss ich sagen ich
kann den die gedanken verstehen weil
meine kinder sind jetzt auch 13 13 und
11 das ist schon ein thema in der schule
dass man wenn man immer noch nach wie
vor cool sein will dass man dann rauchen
muss ja also für diese altersgruppe
fände ich es eigentlich gut das
konsequent dazu verfolgen weil da eben
dieser einstieg oft läuft in dieses in
die sucht und dann aber den süchtigen
sozusagen die er schon am haken sind das
zu legalisieren also das ist ja - das
ist ja ein knaller sondern wir versuchen
das wissen wir aus medizinischer sicht
wissen wir das ist echt ein problem ist
wie kann man dann sagen ja leute die wir
gekriegt geldstrafen wenn ihr weiter
raucht und ihr kommt nicht mehr an euer
zeugs runner das ist eigentlich ein
echten knaller sagen es war wichtig dass
trotzdem für die für die jugendlichen
finde ich ist es hier auch nicht gut
gelöst weil die werbung richtet sich
ganz gezielt an diese einstiegs gruppe
und das ist eine katastrophe für mich
weil der schaden ist immens und man man
kommt oft eben wieder nicht raus lena
ich glaube du trinkst also in meiner
vorbereitung habe ich ebenso trinks kein
alkohol und rauchs nicht richtig das
stimmt und wenn ich mich mal ganz weit
aus dem fenster lehnen darf dann
empfinde ich die entscheidung kein
alkohol zu trinken noch gesünder für
meinen geist und meinen körper als nicht
zu rauchen und von daher stellt dir mal
vor in deutschland würde man einen
führen alkohol wird zu einer illegalen
droge das würde sich gefühl keiner
gefallen lassen aber das hätte ich auch
von dem thema das wir da vorgesprochen
haben erwartet und von daher ja aber die
welt wird immer extremer videos gerade
angesprochen hast ich stimme das
topmodel nicht raucht und keinen alkohol
trinkt wird zu trotzdem sagen geht gar
nicht was soll ich empfinde wissen alles
erwachsene menschen erwachsene menschen
keine teenager die man gerne bevormunden
darf wenn es für ihre gesundheit spricht
aber einem erwachsenen menschen
vorzuschreiben was er zu tun und zu
lassen hat im sinne von wir reden nicht
von wesens verändernden trugen da sind
wir uns alle einig dass die illegal
bleiben sollten haben die zigarette das
ist eine entscheidung die ein
erwachsener mensch für sich treffen darf
finde ich es interessant ist ja das ist
diese meldung ist mir auch aufgefallen
und ich beobachte neuseeland schon etwas
länger und wenn ich da noch ein anderes
fonds auftun kann ideen zusammen haben
für mich ist neuseeland wieder mal ein
beispiel dafür wie wir von unseren
medien systematisch falsch informiert
werden also diese yasin der ort um diese
premierministerin hier auch ein absolut
mitleidlose scarone regime geführt hat
ja mehr oder weniger ihre insel in ein
gefängnis in ein gefängnis verwandelt
das war so unglaublich bei einem fall
irgendwo in einer haben sie das ganze
land durchgemacht und jetzt also kommt
sie mit dieser zero tolerance
gouvernanten geschichte da und was haben
wir in den letzten jahren aus übersee in
der art und gelesen das sei die
pragmatikerin das sei die großartigste
politikerin unter der sonne
minderwertigkeitskomplex geguckt
bekommen als marke mein gott um himmels
willen was wir ein bisschen schwund
stufe bist du angekommen vor diese
strahlenden herrlichkeit der die
aussehen da und jetzt sehen wir was da
für eine also das gegenteil einer partie
gewinnen wird es eine gesundheits des
boten vom reinsten schlages die geht
also gesundheits mäßige richtung kim
jong un als irgend etwas anderes herz
schlage macht erst müssen angeblich das
vertrauen geben oder aber das ist doch
das konto besteht doch darin wie wir von
unseren medien in die irre geführt
werden so könnt ihr gleich weitermachen
boris johnson da wird ja als volltrottel
vorgeführt in unsere mitte stimmt auch
ich habe gelesen großbritannien sei am
untergang nach dem break sid ich war
dort das brummt das läuft ihnen gar
nicht so schlecht also ich glaube dieser
fall hat mir die augen geöffnet man
konnte ein mädchen nicht mehr glauben
ich glaube nun ruhe der welt
bringen das tempo rente bringt die große
wird ich konnte medien nicht mehr
glauben nur noch der weltwoche um
viertel nach acht
noch mal einen wälder ist die evidenz
zur zigarette ist erschlagend ja also
wenn man sieht was die für
schwierigkeiten macht und schäden
anrichtet wie viele menschen leben sie
kostet wie er leibt zigarettenrauch
kostet dann kann man es eigentlich nicht
mehr im alkohol vergleichen obwohl er
auch nicht ohne ist ja ich habe sie gar
nicht gruselig zu erleben ja wir haben
es als teenager für mich entschieden
keinen alkohol trinken zu wollen weil
ich habe sehr früh begonnen zu arbeiten
mit 13 als model und bei einem ausland
unterwegs waren diese wunderschönen
frauen die alle glatte zehn jahre älter
war als ich zu den ich auf geblickt habe
geschlagene zwei stunden später hingen
diese frauen auf irgendwelchen fremden
männer schüssen und haben sich dermaßen
anders benommen als ich noch in meinem
ersten
blickwinkel so begutachtet habe und
dachte ich nein so bin ich einfach nicht
sein dieses harmlose getränk ist in der
lage seinen kompletten geist zu
verändern sein auftreten sein wesen wie
du dich benimmst und das möchte ich für
mich nicht und von da her da dachte ich
es einfach nur mal ganz knapp gesagt
eine zigarette hat diese ausmaße nicht
natürlich in die langfristigen folgen
einer zigarette vehementer garantiert
wobei die leberschäden bei alkohol bei
regelmäßigem alkoholkonsum auch nicht
aber es gab auch keine 61 es geht darum
und da befinden wir uns gerade in einem
absoluten
mentalitätswandel und das bedrohliche
ist nicht das der staat versucht immer
mehr kontrolle zu haben ich glaube dass
das sozusagen eine fast unbewusste
mechanik ist die von selber die von
selber 15 ihr trainer nicht beunruhigt
unsere reaktion ich sehe dass wir
eigentlich
wer waren der populärste politiker in
den in den in den
im letzten jahr mit den letzten jahr der
am strengsten aufgetreten ist undenkbar
undenkbar in der schweiz ein politiker
wie söder würde in der schweiz also aus
den bergen vertrieben werden er würde
wirklich wirklich kaum glauben auch an
den alpen tötete heißt dollar börse das
ist der gesundheitsminister der
sozialdemokratischen partei aber das ist
beunruhigend die csu aus der csu in
bayern also corona mäßig auf der
gleichen linie ist wieder
gesundheitswandern der rest der
sozialdemokrat aber sie sind doch jetzt
gut abgestraft worden oder ich meine es
doch keine agents die tendenz ist nach
wie vor nahe der tendenz ist da wenn sie
umlagen machen die leute wünschen sich
in einem möglichst strengen übergriffen
start und ich muss sagen ich finde dass
glücksbrunn beunruhigend ich selber wie
gesagt ich kann sogar diese wenn wir
jetzt auf die medizinische ebene gehen
das absolut nachvollziehen es ist sogar
so es ist sogar so ich könnte sogar das
gegenteil argumentieren wenn die wenig
lässt wenn ich mein ich meine kokain zum
beispiel war gab es früher war früher
ein schmerzmittel da hat man dann ist
man draufgekommen ist macht süchtig also
hat man sie legalisiert das was heute
als als crystal meth gehandelt wird war
in den 50er jahren noch in pralinen drin
in kleinen völlig neue wenn welchen
küche die panzer schokoladen es gab
schokolade zum verkauf sowohl dieses
ephedrin drin war das hat dass da irgend
auf ihnen ist aber amphetamin das jetzt
wahr dass man im sturm an welchen
dort
wurde verlinkten seiten auch
selbstverständlich hat der staat die hat
der staat die aufgabe gefährliche
substanzen zu kontrollieren aber wir
müssen doch die jetzt mal auf die
gesellschaftliche ebene schon wie sehr
ihn hin dass der staat sein wenn ich
höre dass ich höre dass das ist
vollkommen dass es angeblich von uns
gefordert ist das wäre denn der
privatleute zu uns einladen dass wir den
impfausweis verlangen ich bitte ich
werde niemals niemals meiner haustür
jemandem nach einem ausweis fragen aber
dass dann war überhaupt geredet was ist
halt doch baby wir uns da ins gehirn wo
sonst lasse da ich das mal sagen